ráfagas de disparos al aire en señal de
victoria en kabul este viernes el grupo
talibán aseguró haber tomado el control
del valle de panchir el último bastión
de resistencia antitalibán sin embargo
según los combatientes del frente
nacional de resistencia formado por
antiguos miembros de las fuerzas de
seguridad milicias anti talibán la lucha
contra los fundamentalistas continúa
estamos en nuestras posiciones y los
combates continúan el enemigo está
exterminado he tomado esta arma de los
talibanes sus cadáveres están esparcidos
por el suelo y todo el mundo puede
verlos los combates en la provincia
norteña se intensificaron tras la salida
final de las tropas estadounidenses el
pasado lunes van zyl es la única región
que nunca ha caído en manos de los
talibanes los milicianos dirigidos por
el ex vicepresidente abdullah saleh
ahmad masood hijo del conocido como león
del panshir un comandante que hizo
frente a los soviéticos en los años 80 y
los talibanes durante su primer gobierno
entre 1996 a 2001 las noticias de la
conquista de panshir están circulando en
medios de comunicación paquistaníes esto
es una mentira la conquista de panshir
será mi último día en panshir inshallah
muchos residentes de la región han huido
el incremento de la violencia y ante el
fracaso de las negociaciones para un
alto el fuego mientras tanto en la
capital la formación del nuevo gobierno
talibán sigue prolongándose los
islamistas se están preparando pero
todavía no han decidido una fecha exacta
para su anuncio los rumores apuntan al
mulá abdul ghaní baradar cofundador del
grupo como nuevo líder de afganistán